so hello
welcome to this pi data global 2020 talk
entitled
i apply widgets for education using
jupiter tools to make math visualization
applets for the classroom
my name is jimmy tan and my pronouns are
she her
and i'll introduce myself in a moment
but let's first establish
the point of this talk up front
so as you can see
the point of this talk is basically
about more school educators and students
um the fact that they could be
benefiting from adopting jupiter
technologies for teaching and learning
um because obviously a lot of them don't
slash aren't
so focusing here on math education use
cases this talk
live codes and math visualization applet
as a demonstration of how these tools
could add value in school lessons
um with obviously a lot of different
caveats um
this talk will particularly showcase ipi
widgets as the jupiter technology
enabling
um the front-end experience so
just quickly introduce myself to put
this talk into context i
am a tech entrepreneur with 13 years
experience innovating with data
science technologies i come from a
social science background
um but i have quite a passion for
upskilling and outreach so this is me
at uh the first meetup and our meetup
that i founded
um which turned into a global
organization um and
i in fact decide to make a move to
becoming an edtech startup founder so
i work in the uk um democratizing
opportunities for school-aged children
to develop
modern computing literacy which means
that
my sort of work environment
and my target audience is effectively
girls like hermione from hogwarts and
i work primarily with secondary girls
schools around london
pioneering projects that develop
literacy of different elements of the pi
data stack
so let's talk about
the power of math visualization so
visualization um to express mathematical
ideas and help solve mathematical
problems has a rich history
from euclid's diagrammatic windmill
proof
to the cubic witch of agnesi
cube curve from maria ignazi's 18th
century
calculus compendium and on to
more recently um
uh unfortunately the the late mariam
rizzukani
uh who is sort of well known
for her use of doodling so as she said
when thinking about a difficult math
problem
you don't want to write down all the
details but the process of drawing
something
helps you somehow to stay connected so
thinking about
those use cases there
is a real
possibility for opportunity for jupiter
to be used to visualize math at school
so there are today many digital tools
available for visualizing ideas
and concepts mathematical otherwise
and actually when you think about these
kind of tools
i would suggest that jupiter
technologies should be top of this list
obviously where feasible because of
the professional quality of software the
fact that it's open source
that there are lower barriers to
adoption
um in terms of sort of resources
connectivity technical expertise needed
um
but also that um there is growing
evidence
uh for the effectiveness of jupiter
technologies in education
so you know really it sort of
it's got a really good success rate
and then if we actually think about
why the focus why the need to enable
math education specifically
well so you know i don't come from
education
background but you know i think it was
pretty well known that even before the
pandemic there was a crisis in math
education
um and you know in a lot of countries
western countries as well so the us for
example
um was one of many countries who had
been registering persistently low math
attainment and secondary education
and of course now with a global pandemic
um you know it's it's really clear that
students i mean all students are being
impacted
um and obviously some
more than others particularly those who
were
already disadvantaged or underprivileged
are now facing even greater hurdles so
for example as we should say high school
dropout rates could increase
younger children could miss out on
foundational concepts
um i suggest they already are missing
out on foundational concepts
um and then of course there's also the
mental health side as well
so you know i think this is a really
uh important i'd say
area to focus on you know adopting
potentially impactful technologies
so okay with that kind of context
um let's turn to some of the absolute
demos
and see how secondary school math
concepts can be brought to life
using jupiter technologies this is
an example i just want to show first of
all before we go into
the actual app to be live coded
um this is a applet
which i built to demonstrate basically
the fibonacci sequence
in action and some other applied
mathematical concepts so
things like recursion um trigonometric
functions
rotation coordinates
things like that so this is very much
about the art of the possible but i just
want to show you
uh what can be achieved because there's
a point in the more advanced end
compared to the example that we were
live code which you know
is um more for
some younger age group um and it's
probably
more kind of accessible so
this is um i've used voila basically
so uh a very cool
i think it's really quite new duplicate
technology
which basically turns your deeper
notebooks into standalone
um web apps so also very cool i would
recommend you check it out
so what happens basically in this applet
is you choose different sort of minimum
or starting terms of the fibonacci
sequence
and then it will automatically
really interesting or i think really
cool patterns
um based on random selection of
fruit emojis i've got a dictionary
behind the scenes
so as you can see it's just kind of
visually
aesthetically quite appealing but you
know it does also have
um a lot of mathematical ideas
uh driving it so you know to obviously
get
the fruits to align and so forth
so anyway that's a lot of fun um so i'll
stop playing with that now
um okay and then let's look at the
the follower app of the
app that we are going to live code so
um i've designed this to
take for example percentages
which is part of the in the uk we call
it key stage three
so that's uh the first three years of
secondary school which is basically 11
to 12 13 14.
um and so it's a simple example
but it also is very
short to code as well so you know again
the idea is that you can see it was
possible and you could obviously add
from build on this kind of foundation to
do much more complicated things so
okay what you do is as a teacher maybe
as a student
you basically choose different
numbers of sports equipment in this case
balls or of course any kind of
items i've chosen a sports theme so
let's say
you choose 10 basketballs so
you know you ask the question what is
the percentage of
basketballs in the bag of course the
answer is 100.
let's say we added some tennis balls
and now you see what the percentage of
basketballs is
two-thirds of course then you ask the
question
what portion of tennis balls
uh what proportion of the bag lightens
the bag or tennis balls
which would be a third so and so forth
so you know sort of simple but
i think quite fun because of the
interactiveness and the responsiveness
as well okay so
let's now get into the actual live
coding
of how this is created
okay so let's do the live code demo
so making a math visualization applet
for exploring percentage using emojis
so first step is to import the nursery
python packages
then we are going to select and store
the code points for the chosen emojis
in a dictionary so as you saw from
the demo um i've used and
chosen to use a sports theme
so i'm going to call my dictionary
sports items
so i'm using
this football or soccer ball uh
if you're american
that's the code point so
it's formatting
okay i'm also using the basketball
so that's the code point there
so
and then tennis balls
consistency
and pull balls
or it's an eight ball tankly
okay it's just
oops myself
yeah perfect
so now let's create um the
main function which visualizes and makes
calculations about the set of sports
items
um and so the values past this function
will be controlled by
widgets created in the following steps
so
let's create function called fizz
calc function
and we'll get past something called
calculated item
and some keyword args
all right so
first of all we need to set up
uh that thing which basically
uh visualizes the
the different sort of number of emojis
chosen
as you saw in the demo so this is the
way
i created that
so
using a for loop and then
a while loop nested inside it
okay
variable bag n
now some conditional statements so
it can generate calculations or
um messages to add items
or obviously that something's going
wrong
so
some touch
okay so if there are items in the bag
then um
you can use the chosen item
which will have its percentage
calculated to make a percentage
calculation
then print
the total number of items in the bag and
then also
print what percentage of
the specific item chosen
um the percentage that that represents
in the bag okay
now there are no items in the bag
then print the statement
and otherwise
some error message
and of course we actually want to
show the emojis so
using a little list comprehension for
[Music]
that
there we go so now let's create the
widgets that will
be used to determine the sports items
that are passed to the vizcalc function
so we're basically making an integer
slider widget for each sports item
the dictionary um and then we'll set
properties for each of those widgets so
let's do the football sliders first
name this is the widget
so looking doc you should see
various parameters
set value equal to zero
and then zero max
we'll say 10 and then a description
of the slider
so we'll do one for each
i'll do this in a more
efficient way but
for visibility
we'll create each one individually
so the same value zero
min equals zero max equals
ten and descriptions
okay now i'm just going to copy this
code
because you can see it's pretty
impressive
tennis balls
cool balls
okay let's just have a look let's check
okay perfect now
we'll use a slightly different widget
for
the sports item selection
um that will be used for the percentage
calculation
so we're going to use
actually in fact toggle buttons
for each sports item in the dictionary
and then we'll set the options and
description
properties so i'm going to call my
slider sports item
selection that is
a toggle
buttons because there'll be four of them
again various properties so we'll set
the
options
and description
so again let's just check that that's
working
great okay now let's wrap everything
into the final interact
function let's build the absolute
experience
and also is going to need a semicolon at
the end
just to repress some little text bits
so widgets interact
so the function
then the calculated
item it needs
it's going to be the value passed by
the sports item
selection
support items i call this more item
selection
and keyword arc so equals equals
football slider basketball
is the basket gold slider
no surprise the tennis ball slider
so there we go
there is the final output so
remember you choose different values
and obviously you can render this in a
voila um
standalone apple otherwise
but obviously it still works fine in the
notebook and then
[Music]
let's do a slightly easier calculation
fastballs typeset
and that is the live crew demo
so now we've seen the fibonacci fruit
apple the percentage absolute and the
demo live coding demo of building
the percentage applet you know i hope
it's
clear um how secondary school
maths concepts can definitely be brought
to life
using jupiter technologies so you know
to
summarize this talk and
to really uh
really shoehorn the main takeaway um
you know the jupiter ecosystem very much
offers a range of open source
educational resources that can be used
to build
visualization applets that could enable
more effective math instruction at
school
and so you know for any educators and
students
or you know parents and other
stakeholders
you know i really encourage you to
please take the opportunity
where it might be feasible at all to
benefit from these tools
and access the valuable teaching and
learning outcomes that are potentially
on offer
and so that's the end of my talk thank
you very much for listening
you